et
pour répondre à la demande de ceux de
nos téléspectateurs qui n'ont pas eu la
chance de suivre notre feuilleton
cosmique
depuis le début nous allons résumé la
situation
nous avons à droite du ciel la planète
plate d'egypte
quand elle était trop lourde d'un côté
le punch
quant à jimmy aller d'un côté il fallait
et qu'il y en est un autre qui avec de
l'autre côté à gauche du ciel nous avons
la planète à shadoks
elle n'était pas pratique non plus elle
avait tendance à tomber par le bas il y
avait d'une part des shadoks ordinaire
avec des pâtes en bas n'était pas
excessivement intelligent et il y avait
d'autre part des shadoks spéciaux avec
des pâtes en eau
il n'était d'ailleurs pas plus
intelligente pour ça mais il s'il
n'avait pas été là il n'y aurait rien eu
pour soutenir la planète dont l'espace
est et leur est complètement tombé mais
de ses chats doc là il n'y en avait pas
partout et là où ils en encaissent à
s'affaissait et les shadoks eux aussi
voulaient aller sur la terre leur fusée
n'était pas prêt présent au point mais
il avait calculé qu'elle avait quand
même une chance sur un million de marché
il se dépêchait de bien rater les
999 1999 premier essai pour être sûr que
le millionième marche avec ce genre de
raisonnement typiquement shadoks les
pauvres n'était pas prêt le parti en
tout cas pas comme ça
[Musique]